so please sit down mr. mr. barish ah
well I will start here now at you and I
will add a little Allah record the
session if you don't mind then we get a
sense of the memory you wish to to erase
all right so please tell me your name
and who you are here to erase my name is
Joel barish and I'm here to race
Clementine Krasinski very good now tell
me about Clementine like what Oh
everything we will need everything you
just start talking and I'll direct the
conversation if needs be
okay well I was living with this woman
Naomi a couple years ago and my friends
Rob and Carrie invited us to this party
at the beach no he couldn't go because
she was working on a paper for school
and so I went I didn't really want to
either I don't like parties you know I
didn't want to go so I ended up going
and I met Clementine she was there with
her orange sweatshirt her hair she was
really special I mean the whole thing
with the hair it's all [ __ ] you know
you can't criticize me because I don't
care how I look
it's crap it's sort of pathetic when
you're 30 and you're still doing that
[ __ ] sorry so um I really liked her for
some reason down by the ocean there
I love easily